[Music]
[Music]
when we uh when we talk about rust the
i think one of the primary you know usps
of rust
uh that that you know people talk about
is the safety aspect of us so what is
what is safety safety is god safety is
like you know multi-headed you know
beast
so the first aspect of safety is to do
with
type types the data types
uh now you know there are programming
languages that are you know statically
typed and there are dynamically typed
languages in dynamically typed languages
at compilation time you don't know
what value is going to be associated
with a variable so the the compilers or
the interpreters make some smart choices
at runtime they do some inference
and based on that they do the
calculations
but but this uh
gives rise to a lot of uncertainty or
non-deterministic behavior
when it comes to you know putting things
up in production
so russ is a language which is
statically typed which means you know
upfront
what kind of value you're going to store
in a variable
and
if you don't do that compiler will make
sure that you know
where you don't specify explicit types
for a for a value or a variable then the
compiler will try to infer it
if it cannot infer it will not let you
proceed
so the rust compiler i'm going to be
talking about a lot during this session
because that's uh you know you can have
a love-hate relationship with your
compiler on one hand uh it's the one
that's going to frustrate you as you
work and rest on the other hand it's
your best friend
so type safety is
a key aspect
of rust
the second and i would say i would argue
or some would argue the most important
most unique thing about rust
is its memory safety model i'm going to
spend a little bit more to talk about
memory safety and maybe i will
rather than talk through a slide let me
show you some code so let's go to a rust
playground it is an online ide that's
available so you can quickly try out
some code
okay so what i'm going to show you is uh
to understand rust's uh memory safety
model
uh uh there is this uh
unique concept called ownership and rust
so i'm gonna explain to you through
i'll try and explain to you through some
code samples how this works
so let's start with
you know
some examples so first i'm going to show
you some talk to you about some of the
key
rules of memory management
the first thing is that in in rust
by default all variables are immutable
and when you
move a value uh
to another owner
uh you know or when you when you do an
assignment operation by default stack
variables stack allocated variables the
basic primitive types like the you know
the integers the booleans and things
they are by default copy operations okay
but the the heap allocated variables
like you know the strings
and the vectors
uh they are move operations and i'm
going to show you what that means here
so so by default let's look at what is
uh what is the move operation uh mean
and rust
the second thing is i want to show you
is
when
you know
moving is not the only way to deal with
value sometimes i don't want to move
ownership from one value to another what
i want to do is i want to be able to
borrow a value so i'll show you how you
can borrow
values between variables one in an
immutable way
and you can also do it in a mutable way
then the fourth rule of
memory safety or ownership i'll talk to
you about is
how does uh rust do memory management
especially the you know delocation of
memory so we'll talk about
how the value is destroyed
be allocated
and
last but not least
when you when you borrow a value from a
variable
then trust makes sure that
the the reference to a value does not
outlive the value
so
so let's look at this so these are the i
think if you
if you distill rust's ownership model
you know there's of course a lot more
nuances but if you understand these five
key aspects it will give you an idea of
you know what is unique about trust's
memory management model let's start the
move operation so let's say i declare a
variable
okay it's a it's of type integer
okay and i assign a value to it
if i
declare another variable
and i assign the you know value of x
into y so just to clarify the
terminology value and variable value is
is what is actually stored in memory
and a variable is a it's just a
name that refers to that location in
memory okay
so so in this case what happens uh if i
do a print
if i say
value of x
is
and i'll do the same thing with you
all right so i'm going to run this
program
so at the bottom part of the screen you
can actually see
the result you can see that the value of
y x and y are printed so what this means
is that when you are doing an assignment
operator right on a primitive data type
the basic data type like an integer
the value when you do an assignment the
value of 5 is copied
is copied from x to y which means at the
end of the operation both x and y
have got the same value associated with
okay so this is a very basic operation
now
and and then this is the case in you
know in many programming languages but
what what becomes interesting is when
you look at instead of a basic type i
mean if you try the same thing with
something like a boolean also the same
it will happen you just copy the values
here but if let's say we declare
a type string
a string is
a string is a dynamically allocated
variable because you don't know up front
what is the length of string in the case
of integer if you say i 32 you're
talking of
you know 32 bits or four bytes the
compiler knows it can allocate so much
of memory you talk about string you
don't know what is the length of the
string that you're going to get you know
when you're running the program
so uh so in this case what the what
rusts compa know
memory management system does is uh it
it allocates uh
a set of memory uh in the uh in the heap
area of the process yeah
so
let me initialize x with
a value
now let's try to assign this right we're
try assigning the value of x to y so in
this case the compiler is smart enough i
don't have to explicitly declare this
drive type like this i can do it if i
want to
or i don't need to because the compiler
will be smart enough to infer that y is
also of type string because i'm doing an
assignment operator
so let's try to
run this
program
so you will see that
you know the compiler will complain
uh because it says you know look at this
you know the the the compiler error
messages in rust uh are one of some of
the you know
most helpful and i've seen so look at
this it says borrow of moved value x so
what this means is that the value of x
has been moved to y
okay
unlike in the case of integers where the
value of x was copied into y here the
value of x is moved into y so it's able
to print x it cannot print y
ah sorry it's able to print y cannot
print x x because the value of x has
already been moved so it doesn't know
what to print
so this is uh
this is ownership and action and rust
which means the heap allocated values
are moved by default
okay
now what this means is that at any point
of time your you just have one owner for
a value and the compiler tracks the
ownership of a value through its life
cycle
and that's a very very powerful concept
so what happens and at the end of it
what it does is when the owner of the
value let's say in this
in this case y is the owner of the value
here x is the owner of the value hello
when you move it to y y becomes the new
owner so this way as as as through the
program the compiler checks where all
the value gets assigned to
and that's that's an important aspect of
rusk's ownership model the
next
one i want to talk to you about is
borrowing
so when
you know moving values between variables
is one thing but there could be times
when i don't want to be the owner of
some piece of data i just want to borrow
it for some time and i want to give it
back to you
so
let's look at that example
so let's do the same thing again
declare a type of string
initialize it
so string dot frame is
is a
is a method available on the string
data type
which lets you
create a string type from from a static
set of
text
right so now uh let's create a
variable y and this time y is going to
borrow the value of x so it's unlike the
previous case where we moved the value
you see this ampersand
the ampersand is represents a reference
to a value it's kind of like pointers in
cc but it's not the same here what
happens is i can try to print out the
values of x and
y so let's see what happens
okay so here i'm able to print out the
value you see this so just by borrowing
a value i no longer am constrained by
the you know move semantics because now
it's no longer move it's borrow
semantics so i have
borrowed the value of x
and you know the y so both y has access
to data x also has access to the same
piece of data which is which is the
hello
value
so this is called an immutable borrower
it's called immutable borrow because i'm
just borrowing the data i have no
intention of modifying this value
the value of x i don't want to modify i
just want to use it read it
and we do something with it okay so
that's an immutable borrow
now there will be situations when you
write a program where you want to
borrow a value but also modify it
so let's look at that as the third case
and that's called the mutable borrowing
situation
so it's going to copy paste
faster
now this time i'm going to
try and borrow
this time with a
mute keyword so this is the way you
borrow mutable
the first thing is when you declare x
you have to say it's a mutable value so
this is uh very important by default all
variables are immutable so when i just
say let me just show you that if i just
say that x it's x and if i try to modify
the value of x
let me say i'm going to append something
to the
string
so there is a utility method here and i
just want to say hello there
so all i'm doing is i've created a
x and then i'm just trying to
append something to it
you see it says you cannot borrow excess
mutable because by default uh everything
is immutable in rust
what is
why this benefits is that you know you
don't accidentally uh
modify a value which you don't intend to
so the the compiler expects you to be
very explicit about this and so if you
have any intention of modifying the
value you must specify the mute keyword
so that the compiler knows that you you
you want to do some
state changing operation with that value
so now if you run the program
yeah it goes through so you're able to
assign it
so
let's go back to our example
and here what we're going to do is
assign uh you know borrow the value of x
mutably so create a variable called y
and then
mutable value of x and then now let me
try to
modify y now that y has got a copy of
the data
i mean not the copy of the right has it
has a reference to the data
that that that is owned by x but y
should be able to modify that value
let's do that here
and we'll print out the values of x and
y
see what happens here
okay
now you'll find uh
an error which looks weird
it says you cannot borrow x as immutable
because it's also borrowed as mutable so
what this means is that when you're
actually trying to print something
implicitly the the value of x is
borrowed uh
immutably
right
now trust's ownership rules state that
when you are borrowing x mutably already
you've done this you see the statement
in line number 18. you're already
borrowing the value of x mutably
when you have already a mutable
reference outstanding you cannot have
any more references to the same value
whether it is mutable or immutable and
that's why you're seeing this so let me
remove this statement
and try to print it
okay so here it is
so this is an important
rule ownership rule which says that once
you borrow a value
mutably
the same value cannot be borrowed
immutably or mutably which means at any
point of time there is only one
reference to a value now these are
very powerful primitives
to make sure that you know memory
memory is handled in a very safe manner
because the moment you have a reference
and you pass it around to multiple you
know
variables and each one has got the
opportunity to modify it in an
unpredictable ways so
by design trust prevents these kind of
situations
so that's where all these ownership
rules come in
so that's a mutable borrow
now let's look at uh
we've seen we've seen how to move a
value how to borrow mutably and
immutably
now what is uh what is unique about rus
ownership model is not just these move
and borrow semantics but the point is
that
i don't have as a developer i don't have
to remember
to
delocate memory when i no longer need it
now this is one of the biggest
challenges when you use low level
languages like coc plus plus because
unless you are a very diligent and
experienced programmer
you know these uh you know forgetting to
release memory at the right time
uh can either result in situations where
you have things like null pointer
dereferencing
uh you know so those kind of things will
arise which or you have dangling
pointers
so these things can be completely
avoided or they are completely avoided
in rush because rusk doesn't even let
you do that
what rust does it does is that it does
the automatic reallocation of memory for
you when a valve when the owner goes out
of scope so i'll show you this with an
example before we you know talk more
about it
so we will
take the same example again
let's declare x
i'm just leaving these in there so that
you know you can refer back to it when
you if you want to re-watch the stream
so so let's do this so i'm going to
create another lexical scope within the
scope so if you see this
pair of enclosing braces
i'm in within the main program i'm
actually creating this a statement
within this block
and then let me try to access the value
of x outside of this block
you see it says it cannot find value of
x in the scope
right you will say of course it's in
scope because it's part of the main
program this is the main program and i
have it in scope but
but but the way rust evaluates
in a scope is that this has been
declared within this inner block
and you're trying to access the value of
x outside this inner block
so what is happening here is that
you know within the block rust is
allocating memory and it's assigning the
pointer to the memory to the variable x
but the moment
it sees this closing brace you know it
treats it as the end of scope of the
of the owner of the value which is x
and x no longer exists uh once you come
out of the scope and so at this point of
time
what rusk does is it de-allocates the
memory associated with hello
so uh that that memory is free to be
relocated to some other you know someone
else requesting for memory
and uh
and you know the the so that's called uh
that's that's known as the drop dropped
rate and rust so by default rust
implements the dropped rates for most of
the standard types and if you have your
own custom type you can specify what you
want as part of the drop operation
but essentially
you know the power of this is
rust is enables you to do low level
memory management without using a
garbage collector so if you look at the
uh if you look at most of the so-called
safe you know this dichotomy between
high level and low level languages
is also about you know
safety business performance as a
trade-off
if you look at uh high level languages
like you know java the pythons the
rubies javascript all these are treated
as high level uh
not because they are you know
this thing but uh but because you know
they make it uh easy for you to write
safe programs
you can write safe programs
from the point of view of memory safety
because
a lot of these plumbing is taken care of
by the uh you know by by your runtimes
whether the compilers or the
interpreters or jvms they take care of
the automatic
memory management field
rust allows you to do automatic memory
management without a garbage collector
at the same time you have low level
control over how you allocate memory so
i think that is where
the power of rust comes from
so that's uh that's the
allocation how it releases memory
and the last aspect i want to talk to
you about when it comes to memory safety
is that remember we spoke about
how you can borrow a value
now let's again do that
let's let's create a variable
and uh let's borrow a value this time we
do it which we'll do
mutable immutable borrow we don't need
mute
so uh
again well let's put this within
within a block
to simulate uh
scope
so within the
we're declaring a variable y
outside the block okay now within the
block we're declaring a
value of x
and within the block we are allocating
or we are you know borrowing the value
of x here
all right it's pretty simple
i've just created a variable i am i'm
borrowing the value of x
and assigning it to y
now here if i try to print out the value
this should work
the value of y should work
now let me delete this one
okay so you see that within the block
you can actually
access the value of y
and you can print it out but let's see
what happens if i just move this print
statement outside of this block
it doesn't compile because it tells you
x does not live long enough
what this means is that
you know because x has been declared
within this scope
once x goes out of scope that memory has
been delocated but what is happening is
you see this the value of y
y is still a
wise lifetime is still not completed
which means y still
alive and kicking
so uh
when you here this is a case of a
dangling pointer y has got a reference
to x and
where you know the value of x has been d
allocated so classic case of dangling
pointer
and rust tells you up front
uh that you know you're trying to do
this it will not
allow you to go forward so so what russ
is doing is it's trying to make sure
that the reference to a value does not
outlive
the value itself right the reference to
a value can the lifetime of a reference
to a value can be less than or equal to
the lifetime of the value
and that's what rust ensures and all
this is done through static checks at
calculation time you're not going to get
any weird runtime errors
because you know because you forgot uh
to do the right sequencing of
these of these statements
okay so what we've seen are five
important rules one we've seen that by
you know five or six important rules one
is
by default everything is a move
operation in rust
uh for us for heap allocated variables
then uh we saw how you can borrow a
value immutably you can borrow a value
mutably uh we've seen how uh rust
deallocates memory when you uh when the
owner of the value goes out of school
and
we've also
seen how rust tracks the
references
with respect to the values and make sure
that the reference to a value does not
outlive the value
it could be a lot
if you're coming in from another
programming language but you know
there's no point just telling you that
memory is safe and rust you know unless
you get a glimpse of you know what what
that means and these are the
foundational concepts
of rust as you can see as we go through
even simple programs the compiler will
hit you very hard to tell you you can't
go forward
and you know you uh you have to
accommodate as a compiler
but but at the end of the day one thing
that i have personally realized is once
you have a program that has gone through
all the compiler checks
uh you know a lot of a lot of downstream
problems you avoid
so that's the that's a good thing so you
can you can be
secure that
you're not going to get unpredictable
errors
at runtime
so that's memory safety
in a nutshell field
you